Oh,
a world,
it's Suraj and today we're going to
code up a three layer recurrent neural
network that can predict the sum of
two binary numbers in under 80 lines of
python. But first I want to show
you guys what a genius I am.
I'm going to recite the
alphabet backwards. Ready? Okay.
Okay. Z Y for dammit.
The reason it's so hard to repeat the
alphabet backwards or sing songs backwards
is because we learned these concepts as
a sequence and when data is represented
as a sequence positional memory matters.
So let's say we wanted to train a neural
net on a video of a top spinning on a
table. Each data point would
be a frame of the video.
So if we want it to predict where
the top would be in the next frame,
it would be super helpful to know
where the top was in the last frame.
Sequential data like this is why
we built recurrent neural networks.
Plain old neural nets expect fixed size
inputs and half fixed size outputs to
the state of the hidden layer
is based only on input data.
As it all flows in one direction or
feet forward in a recurrent neck.
We incorporate the concept of memory in
order to do this at each time step we
input a combination of the input data and
the hidden layer at the previous time.
Step recursively.
So if we try to predict the next word
in a song that contained phrases like I
like eggs and I like toast,
brilliant songwriting,
I know and our network tried
to predict the next word.
How would it know what follows?
I like it needs to know what part of the
song is in and hidden recurrence helps
it do that.
We're just fusing copy to help us
copy things and num Pi to do math.
We're going to start out by
writing a sigmoid function.
This function will help us map any value.
We feed it into a value
between zero and one.
It helps convert numbers to probabilities
will also write a function that
generates the derivative of the sigmoid.
The derivative is the slope
of a sigmoid at a given point.
The derivative will help us to calculate
our error during training. Later on.
Next we're going to create a lookup
table that maps integers to their binary
representations.
We'll initialize it as empty and set a
max length of the binary numbers we'll be
adding.
Then will compute the largest number of
possible to represent with the binary
link we chose eight.
Our lookup table is then
filled with binary numbers
so that we can easily return
the binary value of any integer we input.
Now it's time to initialize
our input variables.
First we'll set our learning rate,
then our input dimensions.
Since we will be adding two
numbers together, we'll be
feeding into bits strings,
one character at a time, so we need
to have two inputs to the network.
One for each of the numbers being added,
hidden,
dim defines the size of our hidden layer
that we'll be storing our carry bit.
And lastly, we define our output
size. Since we're only predicting one,
some will say to one well initialize
three matrices of synapses.
The first synapse matrix connects
our input layer to our hidden layer,
so it has two rows and 16 columns.
The next thing APP's Matrix connects
are hidden layer to our output layer,
so it has 16 rows and one column.
The last snaps connects are hidden
layer and the previous time step to the
hidden layer in the current time step,
it connects the hidden layer
in the current time. Step two,
the hidden layer in the next time
step. Well, just to keep on using it,
so 16 rows and 16 columns.
Next,
we need three variables to store the
synapse updates for each of the matrices.
Once we have enough sinaps updates will
update the matrix seats. All right,
let's start training it to kill humans.
I mean, uh, predict binary songs. Yeah,
we're going to iterate over
10,000 training samples.
We'll start by generating
some random addition problem.
We'll initialize our first variable to
use our lookup table to find the binary
form of it and story in a, then
we'll do the same thing for B. Well,
some both integers and get the binary
and coding for the some see what this
store that neural networks
predictions and an empty binary array,
which we'll call d will reset the
air measure to zero every time.
This will help us see how each new bit
of data contributes to our predictions.
We then initialize two lists.
They will keep track of the layer two
derivatives and layer one values at each
time step and since time step
zero has no previous hidden layer,
we initialize one that's off.
Okay.
Now we're ready to iterate through the
binary representation or generate an
input first. This is a list of two
numbers, one for May and one from B.
Y is the output and is the value of
the correct answer, either one or zero.
Now it's time for the real
magic step of neural networks.
We construct our hidden layer by
propagating our input to the hidden layer.
Then we propagate from the previous
hidden layer to the current hidden layer.
We some both of these two vectors and
passed them through the sigmoid function.
After both the previous hidden layer
and input have been propagated through
their various matrices.
We some the information well
then construct our output layer.
It propagates the hidden layer to the
output. In order to make a prediction,
we can't forget to compute how
much the prediction missed.
We'll store the derivative analyst
holding the derivative at each time step.
Then we'll calculate the sum of the
absolute errors to track propagation.
We'll end up with a some of the
error at each binary position.
We'll then need to round the output
to a binary value in storage in the
designated slot.
We copy the layer one value into an array
so that at the next time that we can
apply the hidden layer at the current one.
Okay,
so we've done the forward
propagation for all time steps.
We've computed derivatives at the
upper layers and stored them in a list.
Now it's time to back propagate.
Starting with the last time stepped
and propagating to the first.
We indexed the input
data just like before,
and select the current hidden layer from
the list and the previous hidden layer.
Then the current output layer,
it's time to compute the
current hidden layer error.
Given the error at the hidden layer from
the future and the error at the current
output layer.
Yay.
All of our derivatives have been back
propagated at this current time step,
so we can construct our synapse updates.
We're not actually updating them yet.
Those ones back prop is done.
Then we update our synapses
using the learning rate.
We initialized then MTV update variables.
Let's see some results.
The predicted value is
pretty off the mark at first,
but with each iteration gets better.
If you want to learn more
about recurrent neural nets,
check out the description for links
and hit that subscribe button.
For more programming videos. For now, I've
got to go synchronize them. Go routines,
so thanks for watching.